justement on va parler bien du fond de
la question de la crise de renault vous
avez été questionné à plusieurs fois sur
ce sujet lors de cette séance de
questions d'actualité
certains sénateurs disent que l'argent
public accompagne des suppressions
d'emplois même si ce ne sont pas des
licenciements c'est que vous l'avez dit
est ce que vous comprenez que ça cela
choque certains côtés moi je suis dans
une génération d'une génération qui a vu
partir des pans entiers de l'industrie
qui a vu partir la sidérurgie qui a vu
partir le textile au début on dit que ça
va tenir et après on ne fait rien et on
n'accompagne pas parce que la
compétitivité mondiale est ce qu'elle
est renault est en difficulté moi je ne
suis pas dans le déni
je sais que renault est en difficulté et
je ne le cache pas il est salarié le
comprennent d'ailleurs est donc
aujourd'hui ce qui est en jeu c'est de
sauver renault et pas seulement de le
sauver en mettant de l'argent public
c'est de sauver renault pour qu elles
puissent construire sa trajectoire
future et bien qu'elle soit au rendez
vous demain qu'elle puisse se
transformer et aller vers les moteurs et
les voitures les plus écologiques vers
les voitures les plus modernes
c'est ça que nous faisons aujourd'hui et
le travail que nous menons avec les
organisations syndicales nous ne les
avons réunis hier sur le site de
maubeuge
nous les avons vu la semaine dernière au
niveau des équipes pour partager la
situation ce travail de dialogue social
exemplaire nous devons continuer à le
mener mais ne nous trompons pas de
combat aujourd'hui l'enjeu pour renault
c'est un enjeu de baisse massive des
commandes c'est pas un enjeu de
délocalisations comme j'ai pu l'entendre
tout renault souffre les il y a plus de
dix mille suppressions d'emplois en
dehors de france chez renault
et il n'est pas vrai de dire qu'il ya
des sites qui travaillent sept jours sur
sept et qui serait accablé par les
comment ce qu'il faut malheureusement
c'est un problème qui est globale
mondiale qui n'est d'ailleurs pas
seulement inhérents à renault est ce
qu'un échange des 5 milliards de prêts
garantis par l'état il faut en demander
plus
arnaud on a entendu il ya la
préservation du site de maubeuge masque
il faut demander ya par exemple des
relocalisations plus clair quantifier
sur des modèles précis des préservation
d'autres mais je crois que nous avons
obtenu des relocalisations précise
lorsqu'on dit que le moteur électrique
qui aurait dû être fabriqués en chine
sera fabriqué en france
c'est une avancée majeure ce sont des
amis également des baisses
d'investissements c'est des centaines de
millions d'euros d'investissements
ça c'est du concret moi je ne nourris
pas de 10 des vagues d'incohérences je
regarde la réalité
je suis au service des salariés pour
maintenir les compétences sur le
territoire pour maintenir les sites mais
pour maintenir les sites pour un futur
qui est soutenable pas pour découvrir
dans trois ans quatre ans que ces sites
devront fermer parce que ils ne savent
pas faire face à la concurrence
eh bien merci